okay so this is it now what we did was
we got the equation of this thing but we
kind of kind of did it with a bit of a
hack we were like oh I sort of know what
kind of a line that is and then I think
you're remembering we've got y equals
looks like 2/3 X 2/3 X plus 2 does that
look right because you've got your y
intercept up there and so on okay but as
it happens I actually can't pull out
this trick yeah and it will work it will
work for me if I'm careful with it okay
so here's what I'm gonna say if I want
arguments in particular cases I can use
10 inverse to my advantage I have
numbers here right
how am I going to work out the arguments
just by using 10 MS rather than going to
a geometric argument okay well I need to
know what the imaginary real parts are
on each of these numbers do you see what
see what I'm doing here okay so what I'm
trying to reduce reverse engineer the
changing point of reference so I'm going
to rewrite this like so Zed is X plus iy
right some way to remember us doing this
trick so now you can see the real and
imaginary part there we're going to
factorize it in a second to make it
obvious and here I also have X plus 5
plus 3 okay
can we group that real imaginary parts
what do I have on the left-hand side the
real part is just X that's easy enough
what's the imaginary part I am also on
8y minus 2 what is irrigated and over
here
the real parts just hang together xn
plus 3 okay good now let me try and take
advantage of this right I should be able
to go straight to what the argument is
in particular cases by taking the
terrace of the imaginary part over the
real part did you see that
so the argument should be in tan inverse
on what's the imaginary part here on the
real part which is X and I also have 10
MS all of something else on the other
side right tenemos all the imaginary
part which is why I bought the real part
which is X plus 3 okay
now mark its
right I know what I'm expecting there's
no tan tan inverse anything in my actual
on song right I know what I'm predicting
for this equation okay so I'm going to
get rid of these tanning this is somehow
I get rid of this tan inverse is somehow
how do I get rid of if only I had a
function that I knew about that we're
get rid of thymus oh how about Ted know
what for this um telling us is an ankle
of some kind maintaining you an angle
just like in my angel how'd you pile on
sequencing like that right so I've
gotten a monkey and a quickie and live
the same angle right so if I have alpha
equals beta I should go to take 10 on
both sides turn and alpha should be 20
up right going that way it's okay just
be careful oops the color color what if
I tried to go the other way and say well
I got 10 a dissipative that can I go the
other way and conclude that the reason
that I can't do it is because 10 is it's
really easy to pick an example of this
that doesn't lead to this cake for
instance since 10 is periodic
tanzir should be able to give me another
angle that has the same 10 zeros how
about pi okay that's true but you could
tan inverse both sides and prove the
theory was pi that would be rather
inconvenient that make all of your
sparkles circles very small okay so this
is not true you can't go you can't go in
this direction you can go the other way
so I'm gonna take 10 to both sides then
right yeah 1 y -2 and X Y on it's plus 3
tapi two fractions I know what to do
three fractions right I will cross
multiply that gives me on the left hand
side x y plus three y you care with that
minus two X minus 6
yeah like every check out equals XY
that's kind of convenient that's a
relief right and then I got that to this
I had it enough I had a great example
right so to do that I want to make why
this subject so we're going 3y equals 2x
plus 6 and then I'll just divide by 3
all right hold on
that kind of looks familiar right now
what was the advantage of this okay put
the advantages I can prove algebraically
around shout it out I'm not making up
this 2/3 X business right like the the
algebra demonstrates it for me when you
have something which is more complicated
like remember when I showed it is this
guy you had to yes the you have to
appeal systematic or to - isn't it
difference of squares you have to appear
Susan Audra and then work out you have
to cut out the equation of the lockers
so this is actually a useful trick to be
able to play it but just watch out when
you're dealing with arguments just be
careful with tell us ok sometimes